hi
my name is ryan and this is an
introduction to google cloud
this video is great for anyone new to
google cloud who's interested in
learning more
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
what google cloud is and how it can help
you as a developer
ready let's get started
[Music]
cloud computing is all about getting
things done using someone else's
computers
so when you use google cloud you're
getting things done using google's
computers
google cloud lets you build and host
applications store data and analyze data
on google's highly scalable and reliable
computing infrastructure
google's data centers which are located
all around the world how's the compute
storage and networking capabilities that
power google's own products and services
including search gmail and youtube
with google cloud google is basically
sharing these computing resources with
developers like yourself so you can
build and run applications using
google's computing infrastructure
one of the key advantages of cloud
computing is scale
take an example of a retailer looking to
set up a database to help manage their
inventory pricing and demand across
thousands of stores internationally
one of the biggest challenges in retail
is figuring out how to handle massive
seasonal spikes during the holiday
season
if you were to try to set up and manage
your own on-premise database it would
likely be expensive and inefficient to
provision additional hardware to do so
you have to pay large upfront costs to
set up the additional database
infrastructure which you wouldn't even
need for most of the year
you'd also need to worry about
implementing your own complicated
database starting strategy
managing backups meeting performance
requirements and securing the entire
thing
or you could use a fully managed
database like cloud spanner where all
this is managed for you
google cloud would manage scaling for
you so that you only pay for the data
storage you actually need
google cloud has hundreds of different
products and services that solve
problems shared by developers all around
the world
while it would take me hours to talk
about every single one here's a look at
several different ways that these
products can help you as a developer
one of the first things you may want to
do when trying out a cloud platform is
hosting your code in applications
compute engine gives you virtual
machines that run in google data centers
with cloud run you can deploy
containerized applications on a fully
managed serverless platform
and with app engine you can deploy
highly scalable web apps and other
backend services
next you probably want to store data
some of it's structured some of it
unstructured
cloud storage is perfect for
unstructured data like images videos and
audio files
cloud sql hosts google managed versions
of mysql postgres and sql server
you can run the same relational database
as you know without all the hassles of
self-management
cloud firestore is a nosql
document-based real-time database
it's popular for use cases like gaming
where it's very important for users to
have the most up-to-date version of data
in real time
then there are ai and machine learning
tools which can be helpful if you are an
experienced machine learning developer
but also if you know zero machine
learning but still want to take
advantage of google's ai technologies
for your own applications
suppose you have images
lots of images in your application and
you want to enhance your application by
knowing what's in each image
vision ai provides an api that will take
an image and run object detection find
landmarks extract text and more
allowing your users to use that
information in your app or maybe you
want to analyze user comments in your
application using natural language
processing with cloud natural language
you can analyze a piece of text and get
information about its entities sentiment
syntax and content categorization
and if you want to build and deploy your
own machine learning models you can do
that as well
vertex ai is google cloud's unified
machine learning platform for training
hosting and managing machine learning
models
one great aspect of google cloud is the
opportunity to seamlessly integrate
multiple products to suit your own
unique use case
say that you're building a new social
networking site for docs
you could start out by storing profile
photos in cloud storage
then you could set up a cloud firestore
database to store other profile
information like dog names locations and
hobbies
next you could use vision ai to detect
objects in each photo like balls stuffed
animals and bones
these machine learning powered data
insights might help your users find
other furry friends with similar
interests
and finally you could deploy your
application to the web using cloud run
this would make it easy for your app to
scale automatically as you gain more
users
so there you have it an overview of what
google cloud is and some of the
different products you may be interested
in as a developer
stay tuned for more episodes of google
cloud essentials where we'll cover the
google cloud console the google cloud ck
the free trial key use cases and more
i can't wait to see what you build with
google cloud
[Music]
[Music]
you